und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und claus kleber guten
abend der so genannte impfgipfel hat
gestern getagt das hört sich toll an in
wirklichkeit ist das eine runde von
regierungschefinnen mit einem
gemeinsamen großproblem sie haben nicht
genug zu verteilen
daran konnte auch der gipfel nichts
ändern und die heiß diskutierte frage ob
verteilung über hausärzte sinnvoller
wäre ist eine müßige solange der
impfstoff knapp ist
der soll aber kommen erstmal langsam und
dann immer schneller und dann aus dem
voll im mixed der impfstoffe und importe
genug für eine durchimpfung bis zum
sommer das ist der plan
heute ging es erst einmal darum
versäumte impfungen der letzten tage so
schnell wie möglich nachzuholen dominik
müller russe im zentrum des kreises
düren impft hausärztin sandra heidbüchel
schon jetzt auch heute wieder 1400
menschen sind an diesem samstag dran
es gilt die verloren gegangenen tage
nach dem stopp von astrazeneca wieder
reinzuholen ihre gemeinschaftshaus als
praxis dagegen muss sie ihre patienten
nach wie vor vertrösten noch mehr als
zwei wochen dann vor sie und ihre
kollegen dort zunächst 20 menschen pro
woche aus erwähnen dürfen verstehen aber
bei 20 impfdosen werden wir er wirklich
unser haus patienten wir haben praxis
mit drei standorten ärzten und 5000
patienten können sich vorstellen ist mit
20.000 getan
da werden wir erst mal unsere haus muss
patienten abdecken die bettlägerigen
patienten also alle anderen müssen sich
gedulden hausarzt verbände kritisieren
scharf dass sie erst einmal das
nachsehen haben und die impfzentren
weiterhin vorrangig beliefert werden mit
impfdosen vielleicht weil bund und
länder ja vorführen wollten wie gut
alles in ihren impfzentren nun läuft
ich denke dass es da ganz viel auch um
prestige geht und zu einem gewissen teil
auch darum dass eben termine schon
vereinbart sind
es geht aber jetzt auch nicht darum die
fünf zentren von jetzt auf gleich
abzuschaffen dass es nicht unsere
intention
aber wir möchten das schon
gleichberechtigt als hausärztliche
praxen mit impfen können und da ist es
noch ein weiter weg hin wenn wer sich
die zahlen anschaut die da gestern
vereinbart wurden
während die impfzentren in nächster zeit
konstant wöchentlich mit mehr als zwei
millionen impfdosen geliefert werden
dürfen die arztpraxen erst ab der 17
kalenderwoche also in über einem monat
mit einem großen schub rechnen doch
konsultiert werden sie ja schon jetzt
edeltraud gießen die heute astrazeneca
im ins zentrum düren bekommen soll hat
im vorfeld alles ausführlich mit ihrem
hausarzt besprochen gesehen hätten wie
die lunge nach einer infektion aussehen
lassen sich alle spritzen und überzeugt
sorgen ängste vorerkrankungen sandra
heidbüchel und ihrer aus arzt
kolleginnen und kollegen kennen ihre
patienten einfach am besten
nun wollen sie auch dran kommen in ihren
praxen so schnell wie möglich die
deutsche bundesregierung hat das
nachbarland polen heute zum hochrisiko
gebiet erklärt auch dort ist die
entwicklung immer mehr im griff des
gefährlich mutierten virus polen hat
anderthalb mal soviel neuinfektionen wie
deutschland mit nur halb so vielen
menschen
dara hassanzadeh berichtet die dritte
corona welle zwingt polen in den dritten
shutdown
ab heute hat die regierung das land
wieder heruntergefahren geschäfte
schulen kinos oder theater geschlossen
geöffnet bleibt das nötigste supermärkte
friseure apotheken auch kleine läden und
mit ansturm muss rechnen wer es musik
zum mitnehmen verkauft die polen sind
gespalten in der frage ob dieser london
sein
das mochte keinen gelobter uns das führt
dazu dass unternehmen zusammenbrechen
geschäfte pleite gehen menschen müssen
ersparnisse ausgeben um zu überleben
ich mag es wirklich nicht ist zerstört
menschen geistiges zerstört kinder die
zu hause bleiben müssen und überhaupt
keinen kontakt zu gleichaltrigen haben
es geht nicht darum ob wir es wollen
oder nicht es muss sein denn der letzte
shutdown hat gezeigt es reicht nicht den
shutdown nur für eine kurze weile zu
ertragen und dann verhalten sich die
leute wieder wie bilder
grund für den shutdown das
gesundheitswesen steht vor dem kollaps
es droht ein mangel an beatmungsgeräten
und intensivbetten es kassiert die
hochansteckende britische variante und
trifft vor allem jüngere menschen vor
unseren augen sterben 36-jährige 40
jährige patientin auf unserer
intensivstation liegen nebeneinander
eine mutter mit ihrem sohn beide unter
künstlicher beatmung das sind tragödien
trotz dieser lage in den krankenhäusern
sind nach den neuesten umfragen 50
prozent der polen gegen den dritten
shutout
45 da für beide lager ein könnte ein
schneller erfolg das weiß auch die
regierung
die polnische regierung er lag weder der
history noch panik und hat das impfen
mit dem astra zeneca impfstoff nicht
ausgesetzt
wir haben ein paar tausend impfstoffe
die in den im stationen liegen und nicht
benutzt wurden weil die patienten nicht
kamen
doch zu herdenimmunität ist es auch in
polen noch ein weiter weg bisher wurden
knapp 5 millionen menschen geimpft von
38 millionen zu allen aspekten fragen
und problemen rund um das thema pandemie
bietet zdf heute ausgezeichnete
erklärungen und hintergrund nachrichten
von gundula gause
es waren mehr als 20.000 menschen die in
kassel dem aufruf der sogenannten
querdenker szene folgten und gegen die
korona maßnahmen demonstrierten
zugelassen waren nur 6000 und auflagen
wurden missachtet viele trugen weder
masken noch hielten sie abstand als
teilnehmer versuchten eine kette von
einsatzkräften zu durchbrechen kam es zu
ausschreitungen
viel kleiner war eine querdenker demo in
berlin der sich auch rechtsextreme und
reichsbrücke anschlossen
wegen der pandemie dürfen zu den
olympischen sommerspielen in tokio keine
ausländischen fans nach japan einreisen
diese entscheidung des
organisationskomitees gilt auch für die
paralympics in tokio hatte man mit
630.000 tickets für ausländische
zuschauer gerechnet die absage führt zu
einnahmeausfällen von rund 800 millionen
euro
vor der küste libyens hat das private
hilfsschiffen viking mehr als 100
menschen aus seenot gerettet die
migranten aus afrika waren auf einem
völlig überbesetzten schlauchboot
wir versuchen so über das mittelmeer
nach europa zu gelangen hatten im
vergangenen jahr 1200 menschen ihr leben
verloren
in myanmar sind bei protesten gegen die
militärjunta erneut mehrere menschen
getötet worden
die sicherheitskräfte setzten landesweit
scharfer munition und tränengas gegen
die demonstranten ein
bürgerrechtler gehen von bislang mehr
als 230 todesopfern aus trotz der gewalt
beteiligen sich weiterhin tausende an
den täglichen protesten
sie fordern die freilassung der
entmachteten regierungschefin sun tzu
chi und die rückkehr zur demokratie
der türkische präsident erdogan hat sich
heute zu seiner überzeugung bekannt ist
für sein land ausgetreten aus der
istanbul konvention zur bekämpfung von
gewalt gegen frauen vor zehn jahren
hatte diese selbe übereinkunft ist
europarates noch persönlich in istanbul
unterzeichnet
die konvention hat die lage der frauen
in der türkei aber nicht verbessert die
zahl der frauenmorde ist zwischen 2015
und 2016 um etwa 60 prozent gestiegen
von 303 auf fast 500 fälle fast immer
wurden sie opfer von männern mit denen
sie eine beziehung hatten
man kann erdogan nicht unterstellen dass
er das gut heißt aber für ihn ist es
wichtiger frauen in den strukturen des
vergangenen jahrhunderts zu halten
als wirksam für ihren schutz zu kämpfen
seine basis soll es ihm danken
jörg brase ist für uns in istanbul auch
wieder nach kassel im hat wenig
geschlafen in der vergangenen nacht sie
half die demo in istanbul zu
organisieren
es blieben ihr nur wenige stunden doch
tausende sind gekommen
federn ist wütend für sie war die
konvention so etwas wie eine
lebensaufgabe aus der istanbul
konvention auszutreten bedeutet dass
dutzende von frauen vergewaltigt und
ermordet werden
dafür haben sie jetzt den weg frei
gemacht diejenigen die diese
entscheidung getroffen haben sind
verantwortlich für mord körperverletzung
vergewaltigung und jeder
von gewalt gegen frauen gerade erst hat
ein neuer fall das land erschüttert ein
mann verprügelt seine ex frau auf
offener straße und immer wieder
frauenmorde 77 sollen es bereits in
diesem jahr seien über 400 im vergangen
in einem image video zum frauentag
verurteilen erdogan und seine gattin
solche verbrechen gewalt gegen frauen so
erdogan sei ein verrat an der
menschlichkeit die konvention aber die
den staat zum schutz der frauen
verpflichtet und dir damals selbst
annahm bezeichnet er heute als angriff
auf die traditionelle türkische familie
im westen zerbrechen die familien weil
die frauen von ihren familien entfremdet
werden und nun versuchen sie uns dieses
spiel ebenfalls aufzufinden
der grund für den austritt den erdogan
vergangenen nacht per dekret erklärte
liegt aber weniger im ausland sondern
eher zu hause
erdogan gab dem druck ultrakonservative
kreise wie der islamistischen zahl der
partei nach die sieht in der konvention
den grund für die vielen ehescheidungen
erdogan fische in konservativen milieu
nach wählerstimmen sagt die parlaments
abgeordnete hella gut und er tue das auf
kosten der frauen
wir haben die ganze zeit gesagt dass
diese regierung eine frauenfeindliche
politik macht sie fördert männlicher
herrschaft und gewalt sie wollen uns
frauen zu hause in den vier wänden
einschließen den plan aus der istanbul
konvention auszutreten gibt es schon
lange wegen des drucks dem wir frauen
gemacht haben war das aber nicht so
einfach deshalb haben sie es täten in
der nacht getan ohne es vorher
anzukündigen
finger weg von der istanbul konvention
rufen sie doch es scheint zu spät für
diese frauen in der türkei war das heute
ein schwarzer tag auf island ist nach
einer reihe von erdbeben der vulkan vor
grad als fieber ausgebrochen
auf hunderten metern riss der boden auf
lava trat aus und färbte auch den
nachthimmel roth der vulkan zuletzt vor
etwa 900 jahren aktiv liegt nicht weit
von reykjavik in der nähe des
internationalen flughafens mit einer
störung des europäischen flugverkehrs
wie 2010 ist nicht zu rechnen
damals brach der vulkan eyjafjalla 1821
superzahl 7 weitere gewinnzahlen auf
lotto zdf de und im zdf text
das wetter spielt zum kalendarischen
frühlingsanfang an diesem wochenende
nicht mit etwas regen oder schnee fällt
morgen erst in der mitte später im süden
die sonne scheint nur im norden dort
gibt es lebhafter nordwestwind die
temperaturen null grad am alpenrand und
11 grad im saarland
am montag wird es noch leicht
unbeständig ab dienstag aber meist
trocken und es wird etwas wärmer zur
wochenmitte auf steigen die temperaturen
auf acht bis 15 grad
heute abend in berlin eine sensation
was mal normal war konzert der
philharmoniker vor publikum
heute macht das gänsehaut so lange
vermisst
und man versteht warum gestern abend im
berliner ensemble vor publikum
der schauspieler nicole hollo nitsche
aus der rolle fallen
musste und ins publikum rief mensch ist
das schön
großer beifall berlin testet und will
zeigen was an kultur und gemeinsamen
erleben möglich ist trotz pandemie mit
test und abstand und maske und vorsicht
es kommt unfassbar gut an
später werden tests zeigen ob es gut
gegangen ist und ist lohnt berlin die
daumen zu drücken christhard läpple
berichtet romeo und julia
beim ersten live konzert der berliner
philharmoniker seit über einem jahr
der clou 1000 auserwählte an diesem
abend für 20 euro inklusive schnelltest
geht doch wenn man nur will sogar in
berlin
das publikum trotz der dritten welle und
steigenden infektionszahlen deshalb
schlange stehen schon am nachmittag
tolles konzert mit dem chefdirigenten
persönlich endlich wieder musik in einem
saal mit vielen menschen die musik
wieder mal spüren
das ist etwas was der seele gut tut ich
fühle mich sehr sehr wohl
und überhaupt nicht als
versuchskaninchen ist eine ehre für mich
heute dabei zu sein dass ich applaus
live hören weil das ein geräusch das was
man schon lange nicht mehr gehört hat
vor dem applaus ab ins zentrum zum
abstrich statt sekt und häppchen
teststäbchen in den rachen und schlund
deutsches organisationstalent mitten in
der philharmonie in 90 minuten 500 tests
kein einziger war positiv auch alle
anderen 500 dezentral getesteten konnten
sich auf diesen abend freuen wie das
gesamte orchester
ich kann das überhaupt nicht beschreiben
wie glücklich die sind dass sie heute
spielen dürfen vor publikum und was das
mit denen macht er einen traf ich gesagt
ich habe mir neuen anzug gekauft die
ansagen das thema weihnachten zusammen
[Musik]
kirill petrenko und seine philharmoniker
so viel leidenschaft war schon lange
nicht mehr
übrigens das pilotprojekt in neuen
häusern geht bis ostern tickets
fehlanzeige die waren in wenigen minuten
alle weg klar waren die weg aber ich
kann mir vorstellen dass ganz berlin
davon profitiert dass solche dinge jetzt
wieder möglich sein sollen irgendwie
vibriert hier kommt jetzt alles vom
sport gleich im sportstudio bis morgen
schiff ist schön sonntag nicht nach dem
st
[Musik]